hello everyone and welcome back to the
1858 match between daniel harvitz and
paul charles morphe we left it off in
the previous video we already showed the
first game of the match but
this is a game that happened even before
the match started
i knew that the game took place but i
didn't know that the moves were
recorded so i'm showing it now should
have shown this game and then
went on to the first game of the match
but um you know
it is as it is so like i said uh when uh
morphe approached daniel horowitz at uh
request a match with him he wasn't
really interested but then the crowd
started cheering and then he said okay
maybe we could play a match but i first
want to play a casual game against you
and this is
the casual game that the two of them
played uh harvest insisted that morphe
has the black pieces and that harvest
will play the king's gambit and that
morphe should accept the king's gambit i
guess it was uh
his just his way of checking morphe's
strength level
and also uh morphy's theory knowledge so
uh this is the the game it's really an
awesome game so i'm sure you guys are
going to enjoy it
uh without further ado let's check it
out so harvest uh with the white pieces
opens with e4 sorry about that
uh we have knight we have e5 by morphe
and like we said the king's gambit
declined
will be the king's gambit accepted will
be on the board so f4 the king's gambit
is on the
board and uh e captures on f4 so this is
uh pre-arranged morphe had to go for
this we have knight to f3
and now g5 by morphe uh defending that
f4 pawn
and everything is perfectly fine this is
good for black not a problem here
we have h4 uh this is uh the the
uh absolute best move in those days and
it's still being played today although
maybe not
in serious games uh g4 and now
knight to e5 so here we have knight to
f6 by black and
bishop to c4 now going after this f7
pawn
uh today the engines show have shown
that just capturing on g4 is maybe
a more solid way to play this for white
but in those days bishop to c4 was
definitely to go to move with d5
striking in the center
and now uh harvest can't really capture
uh with the bishop because if he
captures with the bishop morphy he's
very happy he just trades here
plays queen captures on the e5 and has a
nice attack on the knight and then the g
pawn here and not maybe the the greatest
of
moves for black so instead we have e
captures on the e5
yes morphe gives up a pawn but he now
plays bishop to d6 now this d5 pawn is
blocked you can never reach f7 again
and morphy is perfectly happy with this
position so here harvest goes for d4
uh cementing that knight on e5 and now
as this also opened up an attack towards
the f4 pawn morphe defense that we have
knights to h5
uh we have bishop to b5 with check and
here we have c6
just blocking this idea and let me just
check
something uh yeah uh after this uh
uh uh yeah here uh of course you have to
do something about this the captures on
c6 was played
and here uh you have to again do
something about this
i just want to check i forgot to check
if this was uh ever played
in actual games but it seems that it was
yeah
uh from 1983 yeah there is one game that
reached this position from 1983
that featured the move morphy played its
arthur
bromland versus peter varley and the
white was able to win this game
but here it is just uh completely crazy
what happens
uh so here after this d captures on c6
morphe just has to
capture the pawn back but morphe castled
here and this
is just crazy uh i will show however
what happens if you just capture the
pawn if you just capture the pawn
it seems dangerous because white has a
double attack on the c6 square
the problem is uh black is very happy to
give up the rook because after captures
captures and captures with
check you're just going to play bishop
to d7 and the white cannot capture the
rook
if white captures the rook then you have
this knight the g3
and the white is completely lost you
cannot castle the king is in the center
of the board the rook is under attack
the bishop
pair will very soon be fully operational
and just to give you an example for
example you
try rook g1 you save the rook queen to
e7 with
check king to f2 and now you're just
going to castle and
this king has no squares you're you're
just going to completely destroy
uh white uh from this position even
though you're down a rook
so this is what you should play here but
morphy castled here and he allowed the
white a most
most devious idea so feel free to pause
the video here and try to find the
absolute best move for white while i
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting c
captures on b7
that's the the way to go and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
yes that is what was played here point
is you're attacking the rook you're
forcing bishop captures and now the
bishop will no longer be defending the
g4
pawn and it's very strange that morphe
allowed this uh captures was played
followed by captures with check now you
you have to move the knight otherwise
you're going to lose it so knight to the
g7
and here just bishop captures on f4
again cementing that knight here
and it seems like morphy's position is
very active but
uh this is one such position where it
doesn't matter what black plays
black will always be lost and i think uh
since this is the first game morphy
played against harvest he didn't really
try and uh play all the best moves he
really just wanted to test harvest
and maybe even maybe not to to that
exact
extent maybe even throw the game uh just
so harvest would uh
accept his offer of a match but here
morphe played
queen to b6 now now pl now playing for
trix a little bit
uh he's hoping for bishop to h6 it seems
like uh morphe is completely lost
because the checkmate cannot be defended
uh but you actually lose the bishop
captures on e5 the checkmate is now
defended
and after captures you will also pick up
the bishop on h6 but harvest
uh not uh not a stranger to you know
uh such such fine moves himself goes
just knight to c3 defends the bishop
and offers the d4 pawn if morphy
captures he just gonna play rook to d1
and he's very happy here
so instead morphy plays bishop captures
on e5 with bishop captures on e5
and now f6 pushing the bishop back but
it's very hard for for morphe to take
advantage of this because the bishop
still covers d8 squared there's no rook
to e8
so here knight to a6 by morphy now he
has to continue developing pieces maybe
knight to b4 is an idea
and now harvest just castles so both
players have castled their kings now and
morphy brings the rook into the game
rook
a to d8 prepares to capture the pawn on
d4 put more pressure on the queen here
so harvest defends it to rook 8 to d1
and now
morphy gets the king out of the way king
to h8 now the knight can move
and also if needed you can bring the
rook to the g file
so here bishop captures an a6 there's
also the
the idea of bishop to f2 just getting
that bishop there and then
you start pushing your pass pawn but
harvest instead went for bishop captures
on a6 bishop captures and now rook after
e1
uh he shifted his rooks to the center of
the board but it seems odd uh giving up
the bishop pair in
in a position this open uh but okay with
bishop back to c8 by morphe putting
pressure on the queen
queen to f3 and now bishop back to b7 so
getting the bishop to b7 with tempo if
you just play bishop to b7 it's like
giving wider move this way you play
bishop c8 back to b7
and then once the queen moves you will
it will again be your move so queen to
d3
and now rook to d7 uh adding another
defender to the seventh rank also maybe
now you can double up on the d file put
some pressure on the pawn here
but now queen to b5 uh wanting to
exchange queens and offering a rook
trade
and even though morphe is down in
material he's actually done three pawns
here
exchanging queens is uh black's best
hope here because
after captures and captures you're gonna
play this knight to f5 move attack
the bishop and once the bishop moves
shift the rook to the g file you can
bring the other rook to the g
file put a lot of pressure on the g2
pawn so this seems like the way
for black to achieve some counter play
but here we have queen back to d8 by
morphe
and now d5 not only upon push but also
prevents this bishop from reaching
the g2 pawn we have knight to f2 uh
sorry knight to f5 by morphy attacking
the bishop here
bishop back to f2 and now rook to g8 so
morphy
uh definitely has counter play but uh
it's it's
three pawns if you if you don't have
checkmate three pawns it's too much
so here queen back to d3 morphe attacks
sorry harvest
attacks morphy's knight on f5 and now uh
morphy doesn't move the knight rather he
plays rook d
to g7 and now it's a peace sacrifice for
an attack rook captures and g2 check is
coming
and the harvest accepts the challenge he
plays queen captures on f5
morphe grabs on g2 with check king to f1
and now the seemingly crushing bishop to
a6 check but
uh the problem is it's not knight blocks
with knights the e2
and now queen to d6 by morphy morphy
uh blocked all of white's counter play
and there doesn't seem to be anything
white can do queen to h2 is coming
and just to give you an example if you
try something like b3 to play c4 to cut
off this
bishop's attack towards uh towards the
knight and king here
queen h2 and this game over there is no
way to defend against
this uh queen to h1 and even queen
captures an f6
check is just met with this and still so
much pressure along the g
file this will just be game over there's
nothing white can do here
but here harvest shows what an excellent
the defender he is and here harvest
place
rook to d3 and this is very very
instructional
uh because uh uh the the rook cannot be
captured but harvest doesn't care
harvest is already up material so he
doesn't mind giving back a
little bit of material to survive the
attack or something to always keep in
mind when
when someone sacrifices material for for
the attack
and now rook to d3 isn't only allowing
the knight to move because now the rook
is blocking this diagonal but
also covers the extremely important g3
square
what i mean by this he stopped morphy's
queen to h2 idea with this rook to d3
move and this is
insane because now after queen captures
on f6 with
check and the planned move rook d back
to g7 now threatening queen to h1
is met with the very unpleasant rook to
g3
this is this is awesome stuff uh and now
you don't really have anything here
after queen to h1 you can play bishop to
g1
and the rook cannot be captured as this
rook is spinned
so this was harvard's idea and i think
here morphy realized okay maybe
maybe this guy knows his stuff but it
was
still very uh i still don't think morphy
even considered
this to be a defeat i think he just
wanted to get a match with harvest
because he
as we already mentioned he said that it
doesn't matter what stakes harvest
chooses that morphe will accept them so
if harvest shows like let's play for
a thousand horses uh morphe morphy would
accept that so
it was never even in morphy's ma
morphy's uh
uh possible future outcome that he could
lose a match
regardless of who he played so very
interesting
so rook the d3 like we said now morphe
cannot go for this queen to h2 idea he
plays
bishop captures on d3 he accepts this
material
giving back c captures and now rook
and now rook to h2 uh what do you do
here
the other rook can now come to g2 and
here we have knight to f4 blocking the
queen's diagonal and also preparing
knight to e6 which will cut off
the queen's defense to the f6 pawn
morphy goes rook to h1 check but now
king e2
everything is perfectly fine if if rook
to e8 would check doesn't matter you can
just block with the knight knight to the
e6
so here rook to h2 and now knight the e6
even this preparing queen captures on f6
and now you could go for this rook to g2
threatening to pick up the bishop with
czech the problem is after queen
captures an f6
check and king to g8 harvest has this
amazing
king to d1 and now you cannot capture
the bishop because if you capture then
you no longer guard the g7 square and
this is checkmate
so harvest really uh showing uh what uh
what a great player he is so here morphe
adds another defender to the f6 pawn
rook to g6 is played
and now uh what you do here uh will rook
to c1 you could also play h5 h5 is very
nice here
rook the c1 is played going for rook to
c8 and now morphy has to go back
and defend morphy plays queen to b8 to
keep an eye on the on the c8 square and
also attack this b2 pawn but harvest
shows that he has all the time in the
world he just plays b3 and asks morphy
uh what do you what are you going to
play here so morphy
without without a good move decides to
go for rook g
to g2 he offers the f6 pawn for some
counter play but
harvest knows his stuff we have queen
captures on f6
with check king to g8 and now king to e3
again a great move by harvest now of
course this is not possible because of
uh not that obviously because of
checkmate i still don't know why it's
possible for me to do this arrow why
would
the queen be able to do this but you
know
those are the the joys of user
interfaces
so here rook the h3 with chuck king to
e2
and now uh morphe for the lack of a
better move goes for rook capture sun f2
with
check queen captures on f2 and now rook
to h2 it seems like harvest is losing
his queen because the h2 square is
defended but
uh he's actually not there is only one
good move for harvest here
and of course you all see it because
it's the only move
uh rook g1 with check that's the point
king has to move king to h8 and now
comes rook to g2 and
the queen is not lost so here queen to
e5 check by morphe
king to f3 we have queen captures on d5
with check
king to g3 now forcing a trade because
the rook is under attack
captors with check captures and now
morphe wins the knight here
but it's uh uh to no avail just queen
the a8
checked by harvard's king the g7 now
queen captures an a7 with
check and it was in this position on
move 47 that paul charles murphy
resigned in the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
sure he could prolong the game and you
know
deliver a million checks but um he did
the gentlemanly thing
thing to do and he resigned to the game
he's down three pawns and of course uh
if he doesn't expect uh harvest to play
like
really bad then it's really not a
question of who will win this game
so this is uh the the game that got
harvest interested in the match and he
saw okay i've heard of this morphe but
i can definitely not only hold my own
but i even i'll play them many times
and now it's um uh it's interesting uh
because
i don't know if this game was a part of
the match i don't know if morphe would
have gone for this after dc6 i i don't
think it's uh
i mean morphy found way way harder moves
than just uh you know
grabbing back the pawn and even even if
this wasn't winning by force giving up
this rook uh
just for just for a bishop pair is
something morphy did uh a lot of times
so here i think he just wanted to
make the game interesting see what
harvest was was
able to do and get him to to accept the
match so
i think that's the that's the reason
that this game had the outcome that it
did
but okay harvest accepted the match as
you all know we already showed
the first game of the match in the
previous video we are continuing with
the second game of the match
uh which is also incredibly interesting
but this is one of the
one of the finest matches in morphy's
career maybe not the finest but one of
the finer ones
so we're going to enjoy a lot of a lot
of great games here
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it i would like to thank
luis haywood dale cook john ewring steve
green and austin del rio for a
contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank all for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and of course
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day